being probably the greatest economy that
we've had anywhere anytime in the
history of our country we're having a
little squabble with China because we've
been treated very unfairly for many many
decades for actually a long time and it
should have been handled a long time ago
and it wasn't and we'll handle it now I
think it's going to be I think it's
going to turn out extremely well we're
in a very strong position we are the
piggy bank that everybody likes to take
advantage of or take from and we can't
let that happen anymore we've been
losing for many years anywhere from 300
billion to 500 billion dollars a year
with China and trade with China we can't
let that happen the relationship I have
with President Xi is extraordinary it's
really very good but he's for China and
I'm for the USA and it's very simple we
are again in a very very strong position
they want to make a deal it could
absolutely happen but in the meantime a
lot of money is being made by the United
States and a lot of strength is being
shown this has never happened to China
before our economy is fantastic theirs
is not so good we've gone up trillions
and trillions of dollars since the
election they've gone way down since my
election so that's the way it is that's
the way it stands we're going to do very
well yeah well you never can say that
but we're doing very well we're doing I
think we probably have the greatest
economy that we've ever had employment
numbers came out as you know their
record levels in almost every category
African American the best in history you
take a look Hispanic American the best
in history yesterday Asian American
numbers came in they are the lowest in
history the history of our country women
I think it's 61 years and soon that will
be historic too so that we are doing and
as far as employment numbers we have the
most people working today in the United
States that we've ever had before
almost 160 million people so it's really
good you got a machine over there no I
wouldn't come we have a very good
dialogue we have a dialogue going it'll
always continue but we made a deal with
China it was a deal that was a very good
deal it had to be a good deal otherwise
we're not making it because we've been
down so low in trade another president
should have done this a long time ago we
can't just make a good deal and I told
that to presidency but we had a deal
that was very close and then they broke
it they really did I mean more than just
more than renegotiate they're really
broken so we can't have that happen no I
didn't ask him to do that I didn't know
it I didn't know it but I think it's a
great thing that he did it I saw it last
night and they want to look at how that
all hoax got started it was a hoax and
even Muller not a friend of mine even
Bob Muller came out no collusion and he
had 18 people that didn't like Donald
Trump there were Hillary Clinton fans
they contributed many of them to Hillary
Clinton they came out it was the
greatest hoax ever perpetrated on the
people of this country and you know what
I am so proud of our Attorney General
but he is looking into it I think it's
great I did not know about it No
no no no I wasn't surprised but you have
to understand they do 600 billion
meaning we buy 600 billion they buy 100
billion we have all the advantage it's a
very small factor for us and we have a
much bigger economy now you know since
my election we've gone up so much we
have a much bigger economy than China
but if you take a look 600 million
versus 100 million it's a different
world we're looking at that very
strongly what about the 325 billion
we're looking at it very strongly David
I don't know anything about that I read
that probably big news but I read that
this morning I don't know anything about
well you know it's really a tough
situation because my son spent I guess
over 20 hours testifying about something
that Muller said was a hundred percent
okay and now they want him to testify
again I don't know why I have no idea
why but it seems very unfair to me
I think it's fake news okay now would I
do that absolutely but we have not
planned for that hopefully we're not
gonna have to plan for that and if we
did that would send a hell of a lot more
troops than that but I think it's just
where was that story in the New York
Times
well the New York Times is fake news
yeah so you have no tariffs to pay
whatsoever of your business all you have
to do is build or make your product in
the United States is no tariffs
whatsoever so that really works out very
well I think we're winning it when did
we collect these over a hundred billion
dollars in tariffs our people that they
want they could buy from someplace else
other than China or they can really the
ideal is make their product in the USA
that's what I really want yeah we're
winning it you know what you want to
know something you want to know
something we always win
well I didn't understand his answer
because I thought the Attorney General
answered it perfectly so I certainly
didn't understand that answer I thought
it was a ridiculous